Dwayne Johnson and Vin Diesel are both
mighty action A-listers on their own,
but these days, the merest mention of the two
together invokes images of their long-running,
rumored feud. This has been going on
since 2016, when Johnson gave his famous
"candy ass" comments about a "Fast & Furious"
franchise co-star who was generally thought to
be Diesel. In a 2021 interview with Men's
Health, Diesel didn't exactly back down,
but stated that whatever slights Johnson might
have perceived on his part were merely, quote,
"a lot of tough love" in order to get the best
out of Johnson for his role as Luke Hobbs.
Recently, the book of Johnson and
Diesel received a brand new chapter,
thanks to an Instagram post by
the latter — seemingly written
in order to bring Johnson back for
one last run as Hobbs. It started,
"My little brother Dwayne... the time has
come. The world awaits the finale of Fast 10.
As you know, my children refer to you as Uncle
Dwayne in my house. There is not a holiday
that goes by that they and you don't send well
wishes... but the time has come. Legacy awaits."
After some words about needing to wrap up
the franchise to honor "Pablo" — presumably,
Paul Walker — Diesel directly called
for Johson's return. The post read,
"I say this out of love... but you must show up,
do not leave the franchise idle you
have a very important role to play.
Hobbs can't be played by no other. I hope that you
rise to the occasion and fulfill your destiny."
During the promotion circuit of the Dwayne
Johnson-starring Netflix action comedy "Red
Notice," Johnson's business partner, Hiram
Garcia , shared his views about Vin Diesel's
olive branch to Johnson, according to Screen Rant.
Presumably referring to either the entertainment
world in general, or Diesel and the "Fast &
Furious" franchise in particular, Garcia said,
"Look, you can never predict or control
what's going to come out of that world.
So I'm very used to it by now. I
think we're both very used to it."
Garcia also said that while he hasn't
exactly been able to sit down with
his super-famous business partner to have a
lengthy talk about the recent developments,
he's personally not all that surprised
about the latest news. He revealed,
"I haven't been able to really connect with
DJ on it because he's been buried in promoting
'Red Notice'. But yeah, I'm used to
it. It's what comes with that world.
You get crazy curve balls thrown
and you just roll with it."
Garcia's comments are carefully phrased,
but they certainly sound like this isn't
exactly the first time that he's been dealing
with assorted statements directed at Johnson.
There seems to be some sort of unwritten law
that any new development in the ever-intriguing
feud between Vin Diesel and Dwayne Johnson must
include at least one subtle not-quite-diss that
may or may not be aimed toward the other
party, and Hiram Garcia's comments were no
exception to the rule. In fact, if anything,
he was fairly direct in his shade-throwing:
"It's the 'Fast' family. Look, DJ's
the biggest movie star in the world.
No one's below trying all attempts and
approaches to try and get him on board.
So I appreciate it. You got to
take your shot. You never know.
I'm sure there's a couple DMs that slid in there
too. I'm sure he slid into the DMs as well."
Conjuring an image of Diesel sliding into
his former co-star's DMs in order to bring
Johnson back for one more movie makes it pretty
clear where Garcia stands when it comes to this
subject — even though it does make sense that the
"Fast & Furious" star would indeed greatly benefit
if Johnson agreed to return to the "Fast" family
for a final victory lap. As for Johnson himself,
his apparently official stance on the subject
was issued in his July 2021 interview with The
Hollywood Reporter, which heavily indicated
that he's done with the franchise. He said,
"I wish them well on ['F9']. And I wish them
the best of luck on 'Fast 10' and 'Fast 11'
and the rest of the 'Fast & Furious'
movies they do that will be without me."
It remains to be seen whether there'll be new
developments on the Johnson and Diesel front,
or if Garcia's comments remain
the final word on the subject.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.